so obviously you know the one thing i
couldn't get past this movie is that
natalie is convinced that she needs to
date someone like across the country
right on the east coast i know i
personally couldn't do long distance but
nina obviously i know that uh sean is
training for the winter olympics how do
you guys make it work being so far apart
these days
i think that technology is wonderful in
in the case of a lot of people who
either in the pandemic last year who
couldn't see their families who couldn't
be close to their loved ones like
facetime has been such a a blessing for
a lot of people please tell me you are
calling me after the most intense sex of
your life hard to have sex when you've
been catfished but you won't believe
what happened you're telling me the guy
exists and he's there you should totally
go for it i know tag let me make it up
to you i can help you get them
one week no more lies you're gonna set
me up with tech obviously in the film
natalie really swipes through her share
of riffraff on the dating app um you
know generally what are your guys's
thoughts on dating apps nina i'll start
with you
i
have never been on a dating app so
i don't have
that many opinions i have assisted a lot
of my girlfriends in creating their
profiles
craft text messages helping
um
you know sweat like i i see it as like a
video game like if i were a gamer like
dating after my game because it's like
there's no stakes for me so i could try
to like orchestrate and decide the fate
for my friends
jimmy are you pro dating apps i i am i
think that's just the way it is now i
was uh definitely using dating apps
before i met my girlfriend i love
meeting people in person but especially
during a pandemic and stuff not
everybody could and i think dating apps
you got to choose the right app every
app kind of inadvertently attracts a
certain crowd and i think what nina's
doing is is really smart get a second
opinion yes
from an opposite sex if it's possible
because i know guys just like my
character in the movie could make
horrible horrible dating profiles
without even knowing it right
darren what advice do you have for
online dating any tips
um
[Music]
don't try to be too clever i guess i
mean i've only i've only used a dating
app like
once and it was like right after college
and that's the honest truth i've never
been super into it
um but don't try to be too clever you
know i my friends i see them shoot their
shot with these just
horrible pickup lines and i'm like
it's not always the way man you know you
don't always have to have some punny
joke it can just be hello how are you so
well nina i love hearing that you assist
your friends with these apps so i'm
going to ask you for some help right now
if you could write a dating profile for
jimmy what would be in that bio
oh my goodness
pressure
do you want to get dinner
oh okay
i'm an excellent cook i'll put that in
there you know i mean a couple of
questions
i just think straight to the chase is
the is the secret to success with dating
apps like don't waste time i waste time
going back and forth like today
it's all about you're everyone's
searching for connection at the end of
the day
so why not
get to the part where you figure out
whether you connect or not and that's
the only person
jimmy what would you write in darren's
dating profile
i don't think look at his face
you know i think it just needs to be an
up arrow pointing at his face
this is the real me this is the real me
you want to see the rest of it you know
i think i think that's the dating
profile that's it
i want to give you a hug jimmy i miss
you all right
all right darren your turn what would
you write in nina's dating profile bio
oh
shoot
you know you know like what you know
what what what do you think needs to be
in there so
it's a good sell
i think it could also just be an up
arrow right
right also
i mean
considering her
current
dating life i don't i don't think
there's much i think it would just be
like
pass
right honestly or just like i'm good
they would probably think nina catfish
actually yeah
yeah
right
will you guys help me settle it uh is it
better to date someone on the west coast
or the east coast
i think west coast for me i love the
east coast but only like maybe six
months out of the year right uh but i
would say i i didn't know this guy that
grew up in hong kong and then the west
coast there's a cuffing season and it's
very real on the east coast right i'm
cuffing cuffing season what does that
mean
you see you saw west coast you don't
even know nina
i'm from toronto
isn't there a cuffing season in toronto
like um look at this what is it like
before it gets too cold you got to cuff
someone and lock them down so you spend
a winter with them um
yeah what is it what is the canadian
term no no i it's definitely the thing i
just didn't know that there was a word
for it because it sees it there you have
it folks darren keeping it in the
netflix family i want to know about
never have i ever season three have you
had any conversations with mindy kaling
or lane fisher about paxton's path or
what are you hoping to explore in the
next season
zero conversations have been had about
that yeah um obviously we leave off with
him
and baby finally you know give it away
are you here's my friend or is my
[Music]
damn baby
you're gonna make me say it
as your boyfriend
[Music]
it's the ending you were looking for
i think a lot of people were looking for
at the end of season two so season three
is going to be exploring that my
character is the first time he's been in
a
serious relationship and i don't know
how he's going to navigate that having
been such a free bird
especially with davey who is you know
everyone she's always been like below
his social status whatever that means
so it's going to going to be an
interesting dynamic to watch